I'm George Moz and these are my favorite
snacks the Moes family trail mix it's
goldfish it's goobers check this out
[Music]
right look at that it's salty it's sweet
it's
cheesy very basic snack that's it and
thank you I didn't have any food this
morning this was invented by my daughter
at I'm assuming 2 or 3:00 in the morning
I think I discovered it in her room the
next day when I was cleaning up and I
looked at this bowl of goldfish and
chocolate cover peanuts and I said this
kid's going
places look at
that from Brazil it's basita basically
peanut butter salt and sugar think of
like a a solid a semi solid piece of
peanut butter with lots of sugar sugar
in
it
oh you wouldn't really find this in
America American culture because it
falls apart too easily I think you
imagine so many companies in the US who
make snacks are probably like we can't
sell that it's so crumbly look at that
it's falling apart how are you going to
sell this but that's actually what makes
it taste so good you need to visit every
single supermarket in every town every
city every country you visit you have to
go to to supermarkets because
supermarkets are where you see how
people eat even if you're not going to
buy anything just walk the aisles and
discover what people eat out there it's
very
important why didn't you throw this at
me I could have cut it the knife and
ceramic plate this is merked cheddar
merked merked can't actually I can't
pronoun I think it's Merk cheddar okay
from Wisconsin it is not what you think
it is not one of those crappy processed
cheese you've seen before you know who
you are this is cold packed
cheddar spread it is great on a
cheeseburger in fact if you go to just
about any hamburger or hot dog stand
worth it in Chicago and they make
something called a Char cheddar there's
a good chance it's got merc's cheddar on
it it's great it's it's sharp yummy oh
look at this cute little thing of rits
how you get the short on it's so cute
little bit of Merc cheddar on a
rits good salty classic
rits M you can't do that with the other
you know cheese sprads take you s that
is a fantastic cheese right
[Music]
there m who doesn't love
Doritos how about some sour cream with
your Doritos right who knows the history
of Doritos you know the history of
Doritos invented 1960s mid-60s at a
restaurant in Disneyland in Anaheim they
had all this Surplus corn tortillas they
started frying it up so the first flavor
of Doritos did you know this was simply
just toasted corn
with salt that was it that was the first
Dorito nacho cheese didn't come around
till 1972 but something that my my aunt
Susie taught us when she was babysitting
us when we were kids she'd pull out a
big bag of Doritos nacho cheese Doritos
and dip it into sour cream now if you
you never done this you probably would
imagine what it tastes like not for the
lactose intolerant that's for sure but
this is a fantastic moment
here Doritos and sour cream remind me of
my childhood more than just about
anything that flavor
that texture is my
childhood yes one of my all-time
favorite snacks and you've never had
this before this is the ready for this
one this is the choco
Smokey the choco Smokey a very popular
seran snack called the Smokey and the
Smokey the original version is just this
it's basically like a think of a um like
a corn puff or Cheeto right but instead
of being covered with cheese it's
covered with some kind of like a peanut
dust or made with peanut something I'm
not sure and then they came with the
idea to cover it in chocolates this is a
great snack and this thing I can eat the
whole thing right now I may do that
actually it looks silly looks kind of
gross actually
but oh uhoh
uhoh good good luck trying to find these
I'll be taking this with me thank you I
don't know how but like if you go to the
sery market it cost nothing this cost
like a dollar how' they get this across
the ocean
and sell to me for a dollar I'm confused
by that but it's inexpensive but a lot
of times I'm looking for stuff that
looks unique stuff I haven't haven't
tasted before I mean I can't tell how
many times I've picked up a something on
the on the supermarket shelves and Tak
one bite and
go but I do try at least you should
definitely try you should definitely go
into any store you want and try whatever
you can you can stomach basically and
cuz you're going to find something like
this be very happy about
it
[Music]
thanks thanks for letting me uh talk
about my favorite snacks and actually
eat them right in front of you this my
new book It's the Great American Burger
book The cookbook version two it's
expanded updated I'm also opening a
restaurant it's called hamburger America
same name as my first hamburger film my
guide book called hamburger America hope
to see you there we're going to have
Burgers you might recognize from this
book this is a great show by the way can
I just say this is a great show the the
series is fantastic I'm not blowing like
smoke up your ass either
and don't do an animation for that
that's disgusting please
[Music]
[Applause]
don't